donald trump participe au 50e forum
économique de davos s'est depuis la
suisse que le président américain va
suivre son procès en destitution une
étape judiciaire historique le président
des états unis et vient de qualifier de
farce et de chasse aux sorcières tout à
l'heure les débats au sénat américain
commence ce soir grégory fernandez deux
à cinq semaines d'audiences pour
convaincre deux tiers des 100 sénateurs
dont 53 fidèles au parti républicain de
trump une course de fond pour prouver
que le président a bien abusé de son
pouvoir et on travaille la bonne marche
du congrès est le leader des démocrates
au sénat
chaque chômeur compte bien rallier des
républicains à sa cause le président a
peur de la vérité
la plupart des américains je suppose que
même les républicains savent ce qu'est
la vérité et savent qu'il la cache nous
démocrates voulons obtenir la vérité et
ne vous y trompez pas nous obtiendrons
les votes
à force de témoins et de documents il
suffit que quatre républicains se rallie
à la constitution se rallie à notre
démocratie se rallie à l'état de droit
ne se conforme pas aveuglément président
train et son désir de supprimer la
vérité parce qu'à mon avis c'est
probablement qui est le coupable
de là à faire basculer les vins sénateur
républicain nécessaire pour obtenir la
destitution
personne n'y croit donald trump ne
perdra pas son poste mais il pourrait y
perdre la face dans cette année de
campagne présidentielle
car on ne plaisante pas avec la vérité
outre atlantique même parmi les stars
d'hollywood
l'attenté est grande je veux juste que
justice soit faite
parce que nous savons tous ce que c'est
je veux voir ce que nous voulons tous
voir que justice soit rendue
le président américain ne sera pas
présent au sénat lors des audiences
c'est six avocats se feront les relais
d'une défense calqué sur les propos du
milliardaire ils vont dénoncer un
complot démocrate qui portent atteinte
aux institutions et dépeindre trump
comme le malheureux bouc émissaire d'une
opposition qui ose tout une image dont
le président joue sans relâchement donc
coach si vous le souhaitez nous pouvons
avec ceux qui le désirent aller dans le
bureau ovale nous prendrons des photos
derrière le bureau réseau lutte cela
fait longtemps qu'il est là il a vu
beaucoup de présidents certains bons
d'autres moins bons nous vous en avez un
bon maintenant même s'il tente de
destituer ce vous pouvez le
croire ça vous y croyez
nous réalisons ce qu aucune
administration n'a jamais réalisé
auparavant et qu'est-ce que j'en retire
dites moi on veut me destituer
voilà ce que j'en retiens de ce fou
radicaux de gauche ils veulent me
destituer les ça va des agriculteurs
soutiennent trompe il reste derrière
tonnes si une majorité des deux tiers au
sénat en faveur de la destitution est un
mirage convaincre seulement quatre
républicains pour obtenir une majorité
relative serait déjà une victoire pour
les démocrates
donald trump serait certes blanchi par
le sénat mais son image en sortir est
ternie à neuf mois de l'échéance
présidentielle